today's topic Adele apparently she's a
divorcee she made hundreds and millions
of dollars and she's got to give half of
her stuff to were acts of men so this
was from the flare calm it smelled like
a receipt so by Katherine sing a does
rumor divorce settlement is not equality
at work there you go Oh God keep on
going
this isn't what women meant when they
demanded gender parity in a global
pandemic not only are people spending
more time on the garbage fire that is
Twitter but some of their opinions are
becoming increasingly more problematic
ooh
that word problematic gone brother we're
listening to you
so our girl adele has earned some loot
and it would be nice if she could keep
it or at least not be forced to give
more than half of it to her ex-husband
but tbh to be honest that's how you know
it's a good article Oh a capital letters
regardless of the details of Adele's
divorce sediments the whole most
egregious part of this whole debacle has
been the online response sub men online
are pretty stoked at the prospect of
Adele handing a hundred forty million
dollars to connect her ex-husband
tweeting that connect he deserves a
large amount of money and even more
specifically a whole lot of them are
increasingly perplexed arguing that
isn't this equality when it comes to
divorce settlements what women wanted
and sorry gents but the answer is no why
and for several reasons
you know what the richest women in the
world is no Jeff Bezos ex and you know
how she got that rich divorced him he
had to give billions to her and then
what happened nobody said nothin to that
ya girl power who runs the world girls
who run the girls Amazon he didn't say
nothing about that it just proves again
what we were saying earlier what well
the fact that you really want equality
one abyss it's you sjw they want
equality when it benefits them that's
the Equality thing you didn't say
nothing about that when it was the
opposite I don't know if I'm really
happy because my girlfriend wins more
money than me hmm sorry if I end it now
today I don't that's what it is mmm they
put a weird smile in my face put a smile
on your face made the world a better
place
I don't know why okay firstly a lot of
people online are making comparisons
between Adele situation and that of an
Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos who's 2019
divorced from his wife Mackenzie Bezos
made tabloid headlines in finalizing
their divorce
the former miss Bezos was transferred
nineteen point seven million shares of
amazon.com how many value at thirty
eight point three billion and one that
as a twenty second on the Bloomberg
billionaires index a ranking of the
world's 500 richest people well this is
a hefty amount and at least on the
surface makes comparisons does
situations to see more valid it's
important to note that Bezos still
retains at a 12% stake worth a hundred
and fourteen eight hundred fourteen
point eight billion thirty eight billion
is a drop in the bucket for Bezos does
it matter it doesn't matter but perhaps
with what sets a down base no situation
of most apart is that Mackenzie who was
married to Jeff Bezos for more than 25
years played an early and integral role
in Amazon's growth at the companies his
first employee someone who's helped
draft the company's initial business
plan I do think it's interesting that
all of a sudden now this self-proclaimed
walk to vist wants to downplay connect
his contribution to the marriage you
know saying well unlike Jeff Bezos his
wife he didn't contribute when whenever
I've heard people justify the divorce
settlements that men have to pay out to
their wives and people say well these
women didn't contribute to those men
success people say well women contribute
in ways that you're not seeing at home
taking care of the family emotional
support but all of a sudden when it's a
man in the same position as those women
his contributions non-existent
these are your arguments you used
invisible contributions to decide that
women did deserve 50% of what a man made
despite never contributing and now all
of a sudden when it's a man behind every
great woman is an idiot who writes
articles for the Flair what are you
talking about but I never great woman
there's more women because apparently
men can't be behind you unless me plus
if we're talking about equality what
about the fact that even in Canada women
still earn 75 cents for every dollar
earned by man the numbers are even more
ghastly for indigenous women women of
color and listen first off are you
moving away from I was talking about a
white woman named Adele and trying to
bring up indigenous and all this other
stuff that has nothing to do with this
you just pulled a switcheroo okay we was
talking about wolves and you like but
the whales are dying okay let's talk
about wolves okay the big wolf she's
still big I know she's not big enough
she lost a lot of weight right why she
dropped the body positivity to write
congressional the body positive he
dropped her not they did it really did
they're mad about the fact that she's
not about that movement she lost weight
yeah yeah well you know what it is keep
on going it's unfair women have
historically been the financial weaker
party a position that stems from long
ingrained gender roles that have women
working in the home and out of the work
first for extended periods of time
why does Adele have to compensate we're
not saying she has to compensate we're
saying that she has to do and suffer
what men have to suffer that's equality
quiet I do the same job as you you
should get paid the same amount as me if
I get divorced and I have to pay
settlement you should have to pay the
same settlement if you're in the same
circumstance I mean irrespective of what
my gender is thank you equality seems
counterproductive also to be QH to be
quite honest you age in capital letters
don't you think women have already had
to put up with enough as an entire
gender without Adele having to fork over
2/3 of her hard-earned our thoughts
pause pause so what does that mean that
as a black woman because I've put up
with a lot of I don't have
know that no no no that's not how it
works probably make more money with my
wife she taking half no that's not how
any of this works I like that she
doesn't even brought up how men suffer
in two for settlements all she used to
say sir head is basically like women
suffer so we shouldn't have to suffer
here how do you fix anything like that
man in court has been suffering so stop
I would agree with you if you would have
said listen divorce settlements an
unfair and there's no reason that Adele
should have to pay this and I would
agree with you nobody should have to pay
these absurd divorce settlement by
having to pay but your argument is not
that your arguments not that divorce
settlements are unfair you're saying
that it's unfair to a woman who makes a
lot more money has to pay the exact same
as a man that's ridiculous it's a dumb
argument she feels like it's unfair in
this situation you do realize that most
of time this goes in women's favor and
women propose 80% of all divorces so how
am I supposed to feel bad for this lady
when they almost always win in these
divorce summons and if Tom was just fair
and so I was actually just fair here's
the thing when you want to have equality
if either two thing either you see
something that's unfair like the court
system that we changed the whole thing
for everybody and we make it equal for
everybody that's right or equality would
be that if it's unfair to you you're in
the same position well it's unfair to
you to and to everybody that in that's a
position and that's unfair what I mean
by that is that if we want to be equal
we have to be like let's you know what
instead of just meant having to pay in
half let's just really really wait how
things are being reduced and
redistributed or if you're in that
position that you're paying more you
just pay more which is what happening
that equality I think this is good you
know it's great I think this is great
because thank you as Adele goes through
this and may have some hardships and may
be upset by how much he has to pay maybe
she will be a spokesperson for a lot of
the issues that men have been suffering
for for a long time I think it's in you
know before ladies could only sympathize
with some of their struggles but now
Adele's gonna have the ability to
empathize with some of our struggles
because she's gonna deal with it first
ain't got nothing to do against Adele
no no if in the position that she's in
doesn't matter what you if you're making
60 K as
woman and your husband's making 20 can
y'all get divorced you should pay more
if you make a hundred million dollars
right and your husband makes ten dollars
an hour okay you should pay more I don't
care what jet it's not about what's
between your legs justice should be
blind it's bending like that and you
haven't said a word about that and the
fact is it's not been blind and so in
one instance where we see a little bit
of parody why are you upset when men
were finally like yeah it's great it
just shows you how you really feel so
instead of you know mocking these what
you call problematic opinions maybe you
could celebrate Memphis for fighting for
the exact thing that you claim you've
always wanted which is gender parity if
not even the fact that whether it's a
man or a woman that's not what we want
yeah we don't want that well we just
really want the real real really quality
oh she wants special treatment you know
I mean I've been making 75 cents of the
dollar so if women were making you know
a dollar 25 cents for every dollar a man
makes right we've suffered you know we
deserve this
you don't want parity and again this is
another one of those instances where
it's clear that some people don't want
equality they want special privileges
that's it so it comes down to it's not
that deep of a story all right well
listen that's it for today's video tell
us what you guys think in the comments
below do you believe this is equality
what it's not and if not you can just
let us know why it's not equality we
want to hear your thoughts but it's been
like that then again it just goes back
to this subject we were talking about
where equality when you really want
equality
[Music]
why am i happy about this this is that's
equality when men go into this thing
this thing called marriage which is
basically I bet you half my we're gonna
stay together and they lose that that
they have to give had this stuff no
matter what because you know it's early
speaking men have been making more money
than women men or the provider gender
roles and all of that and now she has to
give half her stuff because she was the
breadwinner well they were both winning
bread but she was winning more bread
equate to the same thing right so baby
that's what it is she's been getting
millions she asked to give half her
stuff and people are mad it's unjust
it's not fair when it's been like that
for men that's really quality the one
that wins the more bread needs to give
after is that the rule and nobody said
nothing about that no social justice
warriors
nobody crickets
not hearing nothing okay so that's the
rule that's the general rule so she's
the breadwinner she wants more bread
she gives at first I thought that was
the rule I thought that was the rule but
now you mad because it's not man that's
way too much